la théorie du complot voudrait clé les
illuminati de bavière est infiltré la
franc maçonnerie pour gouverner le monde
alors les illuminés de bavière en latin
les illuminati c'est un société secrète
créée en bavière en 1776 il ya déjà là
une coïncidence troublante parce que 10
776 c'est l'année même de la déclaration
d'indépendance des états unis
donc vous voyez que les complotistes ont
du grain à moudre à ce sujet mais en
réalité il n'y a pas de rapports ya là
un véritable coïncidence
par contre ce qui est avéré c'est que
cette société secrète créée par un
professeur de droit canon dans une
université allemande adam weishaupt va
tenter d'infiltrer la maçonnerie va
instrumentaliser la maçonnerie va
utiliser cette société secrète pour
faire de la politique
au départ un cendrier par une société
politique sociétés initiatiques c'est un
club de discussion qui amène à se
rencontrer des gens venus de tendances
religieuses et politiques très très
diversifiée mais vas-y zobda tenté
d'infiltrer de l'instrumentaliser il lui
c'est quelqu'un qui participe d'un
mouvement qui sont les lumières radical
et celle le mouvement qui sera notamment
à l'origine de la révolution française
[Musique]